Josh actually brought me here
um you know in free agency when free
agency started you know my agent first
day was pretty slow I was in the Bahamas
chilling and um you know I'm asleep I
got the phone like right next to me
um this is the whole day so that tells
you like we had a lot of fun in the
Bahamas but um sleep during the day and
I had like my phone next to me and it
never rang and then my my agent caught
me the night before and he was like hey
you know the Buffalo Bills they might be
interested and I was like cool because I
always thought like I was going back to
Los Angeles Rams like I just wanted to
hear everybody else's you know spill
like this is the first time in my whole
career my whole 12-year career where I
get like recruited by other guys and my
agent told me like the business is going
to like reach out and the next morning
said they gave Josh Allen my number he
was going to call me and um you know
Josh called me he FaceTime me and it was
crazy because I had reached out to these
guys like three years before like not
like you know I was I was just trying to
see like you know how Buffalo yeah like
what's up with Buffalo like question
mark like yeah pretty cool like again
I'm like new in this league two two
years in I get a message from Von Miller
like like this is freaking cool like I
was I was kind of StarStruck I'm not
gonna lie I was like bro how's Buffalo
like how is it man you know I was I Mrs
Poe and Tremaine and you know Trey Davis
and all these guys I was just asking
them like you know how I was but Josh
called me you know we're on FaceTime and
he was like hey man you know you get
here bro like gave me the whole Spiel
and I was like man this is cool man
because nobody else everybody takes me
you know of course my brother's from the
Rams like they text me and they reached
out to me but to like have somebody else
from another team like reach out to me
just you know when you're getting
recruited like it feels cool to like get
that handwritten that handwritten note
or like get that face time and you know
I talked to Josh Allen and Diggs on the
phone like they both called me and it
was super cool bro like to get like a
message from these guys I'm sitting in
Bahamas and it's something it's on my
Vlog on YouTube but I'm sitting here on
FaceTime talking to Josh Allen in the
Bahamas on the beach man it was super
cool what it what it being like what was
his Spiel to you to like get in touch
with me yeah man he's just just like hey
like here's his number if you want to
call
that'd be great
um obviously try to try to convince you
and drag you away from Los Angeles to
Buffalo which is no easy task you know
but I just at the end of the day like
understanding where we're at as a
football team and what we need to do to
take that next step I was just like I'm
I'm all in like I'll do whatever it
takes
um so yeah I was at the golf course I
was actually with Matt Barkley and I was
FaceTiming I'm pretty sure I facetimed
like three or four times yeah because it
was cool bro we had talked a few times
and I was like I mean was like was like
what's up I'm like relax like I just got
off the phone with him I said he's gonna
call me in a little bit
um and I think you got on a plane I went
to call you and like it went straight to
voicemail and he being calm was like I'm
not I can't get it through this guy did
he block me did he do this and like I
don't know what's going on we'll figure
it out when it happens if that happens
it happens if it doesn't it doesn't
we'll we'll figure it out
um but yeah that was uh that was an
interesting day I worked my tail off you
know being big still it was good man I I
felt like I felt like family bro I
didn't feel like you know it was just
dispute to get me here like and I'm a
fan of football too I felt like I
belonged here and when I agreed to the
deal right and I told bean and I told
other guys that I wanted to like I
wanted to announce it myself right so I
agreed to it in like 30 minutes passed
by to be honest I was still like trying
to process it in like my mind like LA to
Buffalo like I could go Rush with like
Aaron Donald for the rest of my career
don't it don't even matter about wins or
losses like I could just rush with Aaron
Donald and Leonard and Leonard Floyd and
Greg Gaines and we're gonna have like a
crazy pass rush for the rest of my
career like and I just kept like going
back and forth and I had agreed to the
deal and being had called me and he was
like Hey so uh what's up hey like what's
up are you gonna announce it I was like
yeah I'm gonna do it I'm just you know
I'm just you know taking my time with it
and Josh had called me too and it was
like hey uh
he's like hey yo what you gonna do like
like all right let's get it done and
I'll lie you're right man I need to stop
I need to stop procrastinating man and I
had posted on my Instagram I was like
Bill's Mafia what's good it's 40 open
and like the rest is history and I just
had to turn off my phone too because I
was still talking to like coach McVeigh
and like Odell and like Aaron Donald and
all those guys and you know it was just
so hard for me to like as you can
imagine it's a big decision yeah bro it
was just because I respect all of those
guys bro it was just so hard for me to
say like hey I'm going man